All right, so the two choices are that it is an NP and it is NP hard, so it NP complete--
4-colorability is NP complete, and the reasons are--well, so this one's true,
we can in fact quickly verify a certificate that list the color assignments.
We actually did that in general already earlier in the unit, so yeah, 4-colorability is definitely an NP.
It's not necessarily an NP because the number of colors is bigger. Well, no.
The first argument is the correct one.
It's not necessarily NP hard because having four colors to work with makes things easier.
That is kind of true--four colors does give you a little bit more slack
and there's things that you can 4-color that you can't 3-color, but this argument
is less compelling than the next argument that says that it is NP hard.
The reason for that is because the solution to 4 colorability solves 3 colorability.
So if you give me a graph and say--is this 3 colorable and to help you out,
I'll give you an algorithm for solving 4 colorability.
All I need to do is add a node to the graph, connect that node t every other node in the graph
that means that that new node is going to have to have a different color
than everything else in the graph.
And now you say--okay, is this graph 4 colorable and if it is 4 colorable,
then the color for this newly added node would be different from all the other ones,
so the rest of the graph has been 3 colored, so it actually solve 3 colorability,
and that's why knowing that 3 colorability is NP hard tells us 4 colorability is NP hard.
And, no no's. Since any graph that is 3 colorable is 4 colorable--that's true.
It doesn't make them equivalent because it would also have to go the other way,
every 4 colorable graph would also have to be 3 colorable and that's just not true.
So this is actually the proof that 4 colorability is NP complete.